the post-processing step in a question
answering task
when doing question answering the
processing of the initial data set
implies splitting examples in several
features which may or may not contain
the answer
passing those features through the model
will give us lugits for the start and
end positions
since our labels are the indices of the
token that correspond to the start and
end of the answer
we must then somehow convert those
logits into an answer and then pick one
of the various sensors each feature
gives to be the answer for a given
example
for the processing step you should refer
to the video link below it's not very
different for validation we just need to
add a few lines to keep track of two
things
instead of discarding the offset
mappings we keep them and also including
them the information of where the
context is by setting the offsets of the
special tokens and the question to none
then we also keep track of the example
id for each feature to be able to map
back feature to the examples that we
originated from
if you don't want to compute the
validation loss you won't need to
include all the special code that we use
to create the labels
with this done we can apply that by
processing function using the map method
we take the square data set like in the
preprocessing for question answering
video
when this is done the next step is to
create our model
we use the default model behind the
question answering pipeline here but you
should use any model you want to
evaluate
we'll run a manual evaluation loop so we
create a pi touch data loader with our
features
with it we can compute and gather all
the start and end logics like this with
the standard by touch evaluation loop
with this done we can really dive into
the post processing
first we'll need a map from example to
features which we can create like this
now for the main part of the post
processing let's see how to extract an
answer from the logits
we could just take the best index for
the start and end logics and be done but
if our model predicts something is
impossible like tokens in the question
we'll look at more of the logics
note that in the question answering
pipeline we attributed scores to each
answer based on the probabilities which
we did not compute here in terms of
logits the multiplication we add in the
scores becomes an addition
to go fast we don't look at all possible
start and end logics but the 20 best one
is enough
we ignore the logics that spawn
impossible answers or answers that are
too long
as we saw in the pre-processing the
labels 0 0 correspond to a new answer
otherwise we use zero stats to get the
answer inside the context
let's have a look at the predicting
answer for the first feature which is
the answer with the best score or the
best lugit score since the soft max is
an increasing function somebody got it
right
next we just have to loop freeze for
every example picking for each the
answer with the best logic scores in all
the features the example generated
now you know to get answers from your
model prediction